you know Harrison Ford's performance in
this movie was actually very subtle I
was very impressed he never once did the
Harrison Ford finger this is a movie
where he instructs children on how to be
war heros the perfect opportunity for
the Harrison Ford finger good job Ford
you impressed me
Andrews game is directed by Gavin hood
and stars asa butterfield Hailee
Steinfeld Harrison Ford Viola Davis and
Ben Kingsley's always based off of a
book that takes place in the future
where children are taught how to be war
heroes because they feel that children
are more intuitive their minds are more
latched into technology and actually
predicted quite a bit of things like the
internet and email and things like that
very impressive actually
basically this kid ender played by Asa
Butterfield from Hugo the Martin
Scorsese film is viewed as a possible
leader for the future and Harrison Ford
is the guy who is basically like his
mentor who tries to teach him everything
he gets sent off in this place with her
other children they're all in
competition to try to be the next great
leader of their army and we can see how
he trains and comes of age and the
results of that Ender's Game actually
really took me off guard I was very
surprised how much I enjoyed this film
asa butterfield again gives a really
good performance in this movie I think
that he is definitely one of the better
child actors working today
in fact he's starting to get a little
bit older now his voice is deepening
he's getting a little bit taller he did
a great job in Hugo and I thought he did
a really good job here as well Hailee
Steinfeld also pretty good in the movie
not as much screen time as you may
expect but she still did a great job in
the movie Harrison Ford was very good in
this movie I was very impressed with his
performance I've always liked him but
I'll be honest if he's in a turkey I'll
say it Myra paranoid this year Wow
but he was also in 42 this year which I
thought he did a really good job in and
here he gave a very restrained
performance he had scenes of intense
quiet that I was really pleased with
because usually he's a very like I want
you to do this dad dad also usually a
very good actor Ben Kingsley great in
the movie Viola Davis also great
performance all around the performances
in this movie were very good there were
some really well-written scenes that I
thought worked very well some really fun
action sci-fi moments too like where the
kids were training in this big open
space where they had like these guns
that could freeze each other like as
soon as you got shot it just froze your
body completely
they held these competitions in that
room that I thought were actually really
riveting the movie also has a very
interesting conclusion that
I definitely did not see coming and I
got to commend the phone for that
because it really surprised me this is
not a perfect movie by any means there
are certain elements in the movie that I
didn't think we're that great the
opening maybe 10 15 minutes I thought
were kind of weak and I was like is this
really how that was going to play out
but as soon as ender got on the ship and
went to the training base it really
improved after that there were certain
elements in the movie to where the story
kind of felt like it derailed where he
went back to earth for this one section
of the movie that no is felt like the
whole movie just stopped basically but
nevertheless I really enjoyed Ender's
Game and I was surprised how much I
enjoyed it it has good special effects
some good performances some well-written
scenes and Gavin hood does a pretty good
job of the direction as well I'm going
to give it a beat guys thanks very much
for watching and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck min eyes